Hi class, Dr. Jim here.
In this lecture, what we're going to look at is essentially the brain and how the central
nervous system all works and really look at it.
But really, most of the discussion, like I said, is going to be focused in on the brain
and what the brain does, how does it perceive things, what are some of the different areas
of the brain, how do we look at emotions, how do we trigger memory, how do we do learning,
all these different things.
So we're really going to spend most of our time on the brain, but the rest of the lecture
also looks at the peripheral nervous system, how that's controlled a little bit and that
stuff.
And so I kept this as just the brain and the central nervous system and then the other
lecture that I have for chapter 38 is for the senses.
Otherwise this would have been like a three hour lecture going in and it wouldn't be that
long, but it would be a two hour lecture talking about the brain and then getting to
the senses.
So we're going to look this up not only for my benefit, but for your benefit as well.
And so that's what we're looking at.
So like I said, most of today we're going to look at is the nervous system, but focus
in on just the brain itself.
So that's where we're going today.
So again, we'll talk about what makes up the nervous system in animals.
So we'll look at some of the various nervous systems that's out there from the really small
and first invertebrates all the way up to humans and obviously talk about how humans
and nervous systems are organized, we'll talk about how the vertebrate brain is organized,
we'll do some comparative anatomy looking at between birds and mammals and how the brain
is organized and what allows for thought and those things to occur.
And then look at what do the various parts of the brain do.
And so talk about what are, what does the cerebrum do, what does the cerebellum do, what
does the medulla oblongata do, what does the hippocampus do in that and kind of look at
that.
And then finally, talk a little bit about how animals learn so we'll talk a little bit
about the neuroplasticity, how nerve cells can rearrange themselves, how do we go from
short term memory to long term memory, how do we learn things and how do we communicate
once we learn those things.
So kind of like what I'm doing for you today.
So we'll look at that and hopefully we'll use our brains today and get some good information
from here and see how the brain actually works and kind of get an idea of how all this works
together.
Okay, so that's what we're looking at today.
So again, the brain is a gathering processing and organizing information from all the essential
functions from the nervous system.
And so the human brain contains about 100 billion neurons organized into circuits.
So this is just a small little picture or small little picture here of all the different
neurons.
And again, they're colorized just to give you an idea of how many neurons are actually
out there.
So that's one small little piece, and the connections between the regions of the brain
are mapped using expression of random combinations of colored proteins in the neurons.
And so just showing you some of the different connections and how they all work and the
colorization, just to give you an idea of how these neurons are arranged and organized
and what are some of the functions of these things and how they all work.
And so again, we only know a small little bit about the brain.
And this is something that we really don't completely understand.
We know how people learn, how things are seen, but where we see some of the most remarkable
things are when people have damage to their brain and how does the brain fix things, how
does it cope with things, and how do they relearn things.
And so that's one of the interesting aspects.
And so we can learn a lot from people that have had brain damage, either strokes or physical
brain damage from infection or other things and learn how they relearn things like walking,
talking, doing those things, and seeing how the brain changes over time and how they fix
areas of the brain that may not be functional anymore.
And so we'll look at some of those situations as well as we go through this today.
Now like I said at the beginning, we're going to look at first how the different nervous
systems have set up now in animals like hydras and jellies and some of the simplest animals,
they have these things called nerve nets.
And so essentially, they have these nerves that are scattered throughout the body that
allow them to sense and then respond.
And like you said, and remember when we talked about the nidarians, they have very simple
nerves that can respond to when things are around them and then they can shoot out their
little harpoons as a motor neuron to send out and trap their prey.
So they can sense it and then they can respond to that sensing by sending out those little
harpoons.
And so that's kind of the idea of the nerve net and it controls the contraction, the expansion
and the gastric cavity, as well as sensing the outside environment and shooting out those
little things.
We're going to look at the other animals here in just a minute, but you can see just
an example of how these things are organized.
And as the animal gets larger, you see that a lot of times we get into these more developments
of our actual brain from ganglia and more responses from those things and interpretation.
So the larger the animal, the more likely hood you're going to see a more larger brain so
that it can basically interpret all the signals that's getting from the outside world.
And so we'll look at that as well.
Now in the more complex animals, multiple nerve cells are bundled together to form nerves
and these fibrous structures organize information through the nervous system and animals with
elongated, bilaterally symmetrical bodies have even more specialized systems.
So we look at the tapeworm, which now has a head and that you can see that it has this
nerve system where it has really two nerves running throughout its body.
These main distinct, almost like spinal cord throughout the body and again it allows it
to process all the way through.
And then you can actually see the little development of ganglia in the form of the brain and some
of the sensory neurons that are actually sending back messages in and allowing for the worm
to respond to the outside environment.
Sefilization is a trend toward clustering the sensory neurons and the inner neurons to
the anterior.
So you're going to start to see anterior development especially like eye spots, hearing, speaking,
you know, all the senses tasting and that and then some of the other peripheral nerves
along the sides that allow it to sense.
And so the non-segmental verbs had the simplest clue to find central nervous system consisting
of a small brain in the longitude of nerve cords and so you can see the two nerve cords
responding to really the two brains that it has and again responding to that.
What we saw in the earthworm in other higher levels you start to see one or two spinal
cords and again a more complex brain as it develops and again allowing it to interpret
the signals and that from the senses that it receives from the outside world.
Now antilids and arthropods have segmentally arranged clusters of neurons called ganglia
and invertebrates, the CNS is composed of the brain and spinal cord and then you have
the peripheral nervous system which is the ganglia in nerves on the outside.
So in the invertebrates and worms you start to see the development of these things with
the spinal cord.
Typically this is remember on the belly side.
So this would be on the ventral side so you'd see a ventral nerve cord, you'd see a small
brain and again the sensory responses to the legs and the arms, the air and the legs and
then you have the sensory throughout the body then going back to the spinal cord where you
see actually ganglia and not really a long spinal cord, well developed spinal cord but
we do see a ventral nerve cord running to the brain which is at the top of the body.
Now in all vertebrates, vertebrates tend to have a dorsal nerve cord because again associated
with the vertebrates and the vertebrae that surround them and protect them but you see
the peripheral nervous system with the ganglia that come off that and so the peripheral if
I get my pointer here is on the sides here and then you have a pretty well developed
brain.
We're going to talk about the brain development here.
You have again a large collection of senses in the head due to cephalization but you also
do have sensory ganglia all the way throughout the body and going down the limbs as well.
And so again we'll talk more about this here in just a second.
Now invertebrates and most invertebrates have glioselles or glia and again these help stimulate
the nerves and essentially what they do is they nourish support and regulate neurons.
We mentioned this in chapter 37 how important the glia cells are that they provide the myelin
sheaths.
They also feed and help the neurons.
They also provide tracks which the newly formed neurons will migrate and form the branching
of those things.
So really these glia cells are very important for not only embryonic development but also
maintaining the nervous system as the animal ages throughout life and going through and
keeping sure making sure that these neurons work properly.
The astrocytes which are the star shaped glia cells induce cells, linings and capillaries
in the central nervous system and form tight junctions resulting in a blood brain barrier.
So that would be the astrocytes that form the barrier and then the neurons are protected
on the inside.
So that's the important thing as well.
And again using nourishment from the neurons and that and form these tight junctions.
And so glia cells are very important for the nervous system to not only feed but support
and maintain the nervous system throughout the body.
Okay now we've talked about this before in the last chapter.
The difference between the central and the peripheral nervous system.
The central is going to be the brain and spinal cord and the peripheral is going to be the
spinal nerves and the cranial nerves on the outside.
So those that range to branch off the spinal and also branch off the central nervous system.
Again the spinal cord conveys the information to and from the brain though you can also
have independent reaction called reflexes.
And so sometimes if there's something where the body does not need to think and process
it you'll have what is called the reflex where you'll get a sensory input let's say from
the hand it'll go up to the spinal cord and the spinal cord will immediately say we don't
have time to think about this send them more neuron or send the signal down the motor neuron
to get your finger off the hot plate.
So that would be the normal reflex.
So if something's hot or sharp or pain your body responds right away it doesn't have to
think about it it just does it because it's a reflex or when the doctor hits you in the
knee that's a reflex it's testing to see and those are not thought about you don't sit
there and think okay now do I take my hand off the stove because it's hot.
No you move it immediately because it's hot your body just knows that it's not good remove
it pull it off of there and that is known as a reflex so those are things you don't even
have to think about then that's a reflex and that's essentially a signal to spinal cord
and returns right away through the motor neuron so sensory spinal cord and back to the motor
neuron almost at the same moment because your brain doesn't need to think about that and
again it's an automatic response to certain stimuli and typically it's pain so something
that hurts or something that's not right we do something right away where we're not going
to say oh hot let's keep our hands on there and burn our hands all off know your body's
just going to respond and it reflects to kind of move that off now we do have in the brain
and spinal cord the difference between white and gray matter in the brain the white matters
on the inside the gray matters on the outside and what gray matter is is typically the neuron
cell body so that's what you see on the outside of the brain and then the bundles of myelinated
axons are on the inside and that would be the white matter in the spinal cord it's opposite
so the gray matter where the cell bodies are in the inside and then the white matter is
on the outside and so again you can kind of see that here because that's where all the
messages are going to come out and then you have the bundles of the synapses and axons
coming off the spinal cord to send down either the motor neuron or the sensory neuron depending
on what's going on there and so again white matter is going to be the axons the gray matter
is going to be the cell bodies which are typically where the dendrites are in that so typically
your spinal cord sending messages out but it is bringing messages in and sending it to
the brain itself the brain is interpreting it and I have a really cool picture to show
you guys here in a little while to show you the difference between the white and the white
matter and the gray matter and show you really show you where all these synapses are coming
from we'll talk about that here in a little while so we'll see that here in a few minutes
okay now you also have the central nervous system has fluid fill spaces called ventricles
in the brain in the central canal the spinal cord and this allows for the cerebral spinal
fluid to surround and cope the central nervous system and so what it does is it allows it
to circulate and drain and that and essentially what it does is it carries supplies nutrients
and hormones to the central nervous system as well as takeaway waste and one of the interesting
things is a lot of times people will get spinal taps in the in the spinal tap is essentially
a needle that goes into the spinal spinal column to get some of this fluid off and what we
do is we're looking for infection that means that you have either a parasite or some other
type of thing typically bacteria sometimes viral that gets into the brain and crosses
the blood brain barrier why we do that is we want to see if there's something in there
if it comes back cloudy we know you have a pathogen in there and so we pull that fluid
off to see is a cloudy or not that we represent now viruses you can't see so in a viral type
of encephalitis you wouldn't be able to see that you would see maybe some swelling of the
brain and that stuff but not so much of the central or cerebral spinal fluid and now when
that happens also we look for blood because blood would be bad news too because that means
you got a brain bleed going on which is not good as well so they do that as well when you
get a concussion then sometimes they'll do a spinal tap just to make sure you're not bleeding
into the brain now sometimes what will happen is that it will not completely close and you
get a leakage of that cerebral spinal fluid and that will cause one of the worst headaches
that you could imagine when that happens I had a friend a good friend of mine that had
this happen he had a he basically really felt I think he fell off a ladder or something
happened and he bumped his head and they took him to the hospital and one of the things
that they're worried about is that he may have an internal bleed and so they did a spinal
tap just to see and they did the spinal tap everything was fine but as soon as he got
done with that spinal tap he had one of the worst headaches and he thought that was associated
with the you know the head trauma that he had well it turns out when he went back to
doc he he was on he was on a trip at the time that this happened and he was actually working
for this company and when he came back to where we were where we were living and at the
time he was like this headaches awful I got to go to the doctor whatever it's not getting
any better and what they did was they actually took some blood and they clogged the the hole
where he had the spinal tap and as soon as they did that the headache almost went away
immediately and that was weird because sometimes the spinal the spinal tap the fluid leaks out
of the system and that causes one of the worst headaches because of the systems in pain because
you're draining the system and essentially the brain's getting starved of cerebral spinal
fluid as soon as they clotted the hole with clotted blood the headache went away because
the system said okay now I've got enough fluid I'm feeling better now and you didn't have
the pain anymore and that stuff and it was just amazing so that's one of the things that
can happen and so why we do spinal taps is to look to see if there's blood or something
else in the spinal fluid that's not supposed to be there just should be clear and sterile
but if it doesn't heal up properly you could have leakage and it can cause severe pain
so I just wanted to point that out as one of those things where it happens and this just
shows you how the fluid actually moves so this picture is showing you that you have these
ventricles that you have fluid that surrounds the brain and surrounds the body in that and
where this fluid goes and you can see where these things go into the spinal canal and
that around the spinal cord as well as around the brain and again it kind of encapsulates
around that blood brain barrier and allows for the fluid to kind of surround and protect
the brain as well okay so that's kind of how that all goes and the waste drains into the
veins of the brain too so that's how it gets transported out so kind of in those situations
there okay so give you an idea of how this all works and where it all goes into into
the brain now we talked about the two systems the peripheral system transmits the information
from the central nervous system and regulates the movement in the internal environment and
really you have two different sets of the peripheral so you get the stimuli in from the
peripheral which will go to the central nervous system which will respond and then that will
send out a signal to the efferent neurons and then to the peripheral system to either
do motor which is the control of the muscle system or you have the autonomic nervous system
which really controls the functions of a lot of the organs so you have what is the sympathetic
and then the parasympathetic which is fight or fight or rest and digest I like how they
call that and then they have the enteric which essentially controls all your digestive systems
and again it controls the smooth muscles cardiac muscles and glands of your system and these
are things you don't even think about whereas the motor system is one that you could physically
control and it's called the voluntary system versus involuntary system so we'll look at
that a little bit more now like I said the peripheral has two efferent components you
have the motor in the autonomic nervous system the motor is response and it can be voluntary
or involuntary depending on the muscles that you're talking about and the autonomic nervous
system regulates the smooth and cardiac muscles and is generally involuntary and so again what
you're looking at here is that the sensory division brings the senses in the central nervous
system which processes then it sends it back out to the motor which will stimulate the somatic
nervous system which is the muscle and then you have the autonomic which is again the
sympathetic and parasympathetic and also the enteric which controls the digestive system
now the enteric division like I said controls the activity of the digestive tract the pancreas
and gallbladder you can see that here where the autonomic goes from the sympathetic the
parasympathetic and then manages every aspect of digestion from the esophagus all the way
to the colon so you can see that's the enteric division the rest of these systems like I said
is essentially how it all works and how it all processes these different things the last
two the sympathetic and the parasympathetic we'll talk about here in a second but that's
also part of the autonomic and essentially how this works the other system is the somatic
which is the motor system controlling the body movements okay so the sympathetic division
regulates the fight or flight so when you got to get out of something there so you can see
the fight or flight what it will do to your system so it'll dilate your pupils inhibit
salivation increase your heartbeat relax your airway stimulate activity inhibit activity
the stomach really pull all the really slow down the digestive system in that case and
then also relax and promote ejaculation or vaginal constriction in these cases whereas
the parasympathetic is the rest and digest so essentially what you have in these situations
is where everything goes back to normal and then it will send and stimulate the digestive
system to do what it's supposed to do so those are again where you either have fight
or flight which is going to tell you to fight or get out of there get out of danger whereas
the parasympathetic is going to be relaxing and digest so slow down calm down and go back
to normal digestion in those situations okay so that's what goes on in those different
situations in those cases alright and so the rest of the talk is primarily going to focus
in on the brain and all the different parts of the brain and again we can look at the
brain by using different technology to visualize the brain activity and processing so this
is a really cool one they always talk about activity and exercise and this will just show
you how you actually stimulate your brain by walking and so even doing simple exercises
like walking for 20 minutes will cause you to have a great deal of stimulation in your
brain and tells you how to be living a healthy lifestyle not only are you giving your body
exercise but it's stimulating your brain in your brain pathways and so that's one of
the things so instead of lounging around on the couch get out and walk for a little while
and stimulate your brain a little bit it's all that sensory that you're seeing in the
outside world and it's helping you stimulate your brain and doing good things now one of
the ways that we can see what's going on inside the brain is this thing called the positron
emission tomography which is called the PET scan and this is an injective radioactive glucose
that enables display of metabolic activity so you can see when you have lots of activity
it goes red and that's where the brain is using glucose and you can see different parts
of the brain and how it responds so like we said before walking so this would be a resting
brain walking stimulates parts of the cerebrum and again looking at the looks like it stimulates
the left side of the brain really well and doing some of the functions would you look
at the resting brain again seeing and hearing seeing the neurons for seeing or in the back
of the head so you can see that that gets lit up whereas hearing is on the right side
of the brain opposite of where you are stimulating for walking thinking typically happens in
the frontal cortex so again you see a big stimulation of metabolism in the front and
then remembering it's kind of in the middle of the brain and in the back of the brain
you can see the difference when you're trying to remember something and ask something your
brain is stimulating trying to find those files that you've stored in your brain somewhere
deep inside your brain trying to remember some of the stuff that you're processing now another
way we can look at the brain is really looking at an MRI which is functional magnetic resonance
imaging or magnetic resonance imaging and so we can take a look so not only can we look
at the brain itself using the MRI but if you use this fMRI you can actually see areas of
the brain that are being stimulated so again this could be due to the amount of local oxygen
concentration so again kind of looking at metabolism but in this case not looking at glucose levels
but oxygen levels and so this MRI can look at the differences in there and like I said
a lot of times we use this when we want to see what is the brain doing to recover and
so you can see the difference in an MRI between happy music and what parts of the brains are
stimulated versus sad music and then one of the areas that kind of controls emotion so
you can see that happy music stimulates lots of different parts of the brain where sad
music only stimulates really the emotional part of your brain and so that's going to be
one of the things that we talked about here in a little while and so some of the different
parts of the brain that gets stimulated here.
Okay now again this just shows you the side of the brain with a fMRI kind of giving you
a picture of the brain we can look and see using these images to see if there's anything
going wrong with the brain and like I said if you do the fMRI you can see oxygen concentration
along with the picture of the brain and what's going on so this just gives us a nice image
of what's taking place in the brain and if there's anything wrong inside the brain itself
and so that kind of gives us an idea of what's happening.
Now just showing you some development we are going to talk a little bit more about development
here in a couple of lectures so that would be back in chapter 36 but how the brain develops
and this is really in any of the vertebrate animals now this is showing the human brain
but really the brain develops a lot of the same way in all the animals and so you have
the three parts of the brain the forebrain the midbrain and the hindbrain and depending
on the animal really shows you what part of the brain is going to develop.
And so in humans the forebrain develops in the two parts known as the telencephalon and
the diencephalon which is in these cases and then you have the mensus melon which is the
midbrain and then the high brain you can see during development this starts to fold in
so you can start to see how all this is taking place so the forebrain is going to kind of
sit over the top of the midbrain and then the hindbrain you can kind of see that here
how this gets incorporated so the telencephalon kind of grows on top and really grows very
large so that's the cerebellum.
You have the diencephalon which is again typically the pituitary gland and the hippocampus and
then you have the midbrain which a lot of times right in this area here which is part
of the brain stem and then you have the pons and medulla and medulla oblongata and the cerebellum
which are in control of both emotions and a lot of it is in control of the involuntary
function so like your heart beating your breathing and your digestive system all controlled
by those things and then the rest of it is the spinal cord so you can kind of see how
this all folds in over time so it's really kind of cool so you start off and you start
off as a tube and then you start to develop the front brain the midbrain and the hindbrain
and then you get this folding taking place which then folds them all on top of one another
and kind of shows you how the brain develops and so again that's kind of cool just seeing
it from a developmental standard of how this all works and what it turns into.
Now showing you from the rear basically you see the cerebellum which again it is the hindbrain
you have the midbrain or I'm sorry the the midbrain is kind of tucked inside and then you
have the cerebellum which is really the frontal or the front brain in this case and again that's
going to be the sites for the sensing and then also some of the sensing of the world
and then also thinking and learning as well so we'll talk about that here in a few minutes
of what each part of the brain actually does okay now giving it from the side here is just
showing you where the diencephalon is the diencephalon is part of the front brain again the pituitary
gland and then we have the hippocampus the thalamus and the pineal gland which regulates the the
circadian rodents which we'll talk about here the midbrain which is kind of tucked in here and
then the hindbrain which is going to be again the medulla oblongata the pons and then the cerebellum
which is back here as well and then the spinal cord and again these control a lot of the
involuntary functions and emotions that we have in our brain as well as long as as well as the
um uh the di not the dience yeah the diencephalon and that also controls emotions but you'll see
that as well with them and do a loblongata okay so sleep what does sleep do and so when we look at
arousal which is the state of a weakness of the external world and so we're getting those signals
in sleep is a stage in which external stimuli are received but not consciously perceived and so
you're still getting signals into the brain but the brain is not interpreting and really
consciously thinking about those things and again we have clusters of neurons in the midbrain and
the pons that allow us to either awake or sleep and one of the big things is sleep helps recharge
the brain so you can see when we're awake a lot of the brain is being inactive when we're asleep
the brain is pretty quiet in quiescence and out of a lot of glucose being there and then when we're
in dream state you can actually see the brain is actually processing and one of the things they
do think that actually happens is a lot of times when we're asleep is that a lot of our short-term
memories are being processed into long-term memories and so that really helps kind of regenerate the
brain and what's going on and what's being done there so that's that's one of the things we think
about there as well okay now sleep in the active state of the brain is regulated by the biological
clock in the forebrain which regulates the intensity and duration of sleep and some animals have
evolutionary adaptions that allow for substantial activity for sleep and one of those adaptations
is in dolphins we're only one side of the brain is asleep at a time and so they can continue to swim
and breathe and do all those things underwater while the other half of the brain sleeps and they can
go back and forth between the sides of the brain so they can do that in humans obviously we have
patterns of sleep and awakeness and again a lot of that's due to the circadian rhythms and so we
can really affect our sleep by affecting our circadian clock and biological clock and i'll show
you that here in a few minutes but you can see again sleep versus no sleep and again you can
transmit in these situations where again low frequency waves characters stick to sleep so in
these and then the high frequency waves are a wakefulness and so you can see how the brain can go
from one side to the other in the dolphins and so they can sleep and for one hour and then wake up
and then flip from the other side so this is what's going on in dolphins in this situation
now like i said before for humans and a lot of other animals we're controlled by the circadian
rhythm so the canal gland controls this and it's our biological clock and this directs periodic
gene expression as well as our sleep and wake cycle and it's typically synchronized with the
light and dark cycles that maintain the 24 hour cycle and you can kind of see what happens in
her body during this time and it is regulated into those things and you can see the big thing
is that what if you work third shift and so what happens is it really screws up your system because
if you're working third shift a lot of times you're sleeping when the body wants to be awake
and you're awake when the body wants to sleep and so again that can really affect circadian rhythms
and really cause a problem and so that's where a lot of people will get these issues with insomnia
and other things is when they're a biological clock or their circadian rhythms are all out of
wax so someone going from first shift to third shift or third shift back to first shift can really
screw up their systems and have really a hard time readjusting to that because your body gets used to
these different situations but like i said even third shift it really screws things up because
your body is normally programmed for light and if it's doing the opposite it really throws it out
of wax and so that's that can be an issue as well and so you can see when all these things
different happen during the day and why a lot of times you can wake up and have these different
responses based on just a normal schedule so if you have a normal sleep schedule and that stuff
you can kind of see how these all these things happen and so again take a look at this and see
how your sleep cycle compares to this situation here now circadian rhythms are in the hypothalamus
called the suprachysmatic nucleus or the scn which acts as the pacemaker synchronizing the
biological clock and again the mammalian body and some of these other nucleus here in the brain
also controls the pineal gland and again it's also controlled by the optic nerve because again
sensing light and darkness and so one of the things that they say that's really screwing up our
biological clock is our phones so having our phones our phones and our ipods and everything else
around us where we're constantly bombarded by blue light and one of the things that we sense is
that blue light and that can keep us awake and that can screw up our our circadian rhythms and
that stuff so what they do recommend is putting away your phone for at least a half hour before
you go to bed and the ipods and anything else if you're going to do anything and you want to
put yourself to sleep read a book or you know turn off all the lights and just in go to bed
other bad thing is tv and so i i'm bad about it and my wife and i have a tv in our room when we
end up watching it sometimes before we go to bed on weeknights and that stuff we tend not to watch
tv trying to put our bodies back into the good circadian rhythm so we go to bed it's that light
and the circadian that affects the circadian rhythms and can affect sleep habits and and that as well
so that's one of the things that we see now i didn't mention emotions and emotions are controlled by
a lot of different things in the body and you can see the emotional center is really the mid
mid and high or mid brain and front brain in this case and again you can see some of the different
patterns again the hypo campus the emla im i can't say this right emla data dala the emla
good emla good dala if i say em if i pronounce it right is the emotional center
along with the thalamus the hypo thalamus and you can see are a factory bulk so one of the
interesting things is smells can trigger a lot of emotion and so that's why they they're now
selling these things like diffusers or a lot of times smells will bring us back to certain memories
because we'll remember all like cookies uh being made in the kitchen all that reminds me of home
or you know now we're getting close to thanksgiving and those smells of thanksgiving
remind us of family and get togethers and that stuff and that's because a lot of times our
memories are triggered and our emotions are triggered by the smells that we smell and so again that's
one of there's a reason for that too uh to get us out of things so if things smell really bad
it's to trigger us and say get out run do whatever you need to do to get out of bad smells and again
good smells trigger good emotions and that in good memories and so again these are all kind of connected
and like i said the emla data em emla good dala i think i'm saying there emla emla good dala
and the hippo campus part of the film is are controlling the emotions in the brain and the
generation and experience of emotion also require interaction of the limber system as well as the
sensory areas of the cerebrum which is the olfactory bulb sometimes sight of the uh thomac low which
is back here and uh the emotional memory is due to the emla emla good dala they're making me say
it enough times but that is controlling the emotional memory and like i said it's connected so sometimes
smells can trigger emotional memories and that as well uh in a lot of people now the brain's reward
system is again in the frontal pathway but a lot of times that's due to the dopamine and serotonin
we talked about this before in the neurotransmitter uh neurotransmitters that dopamine and serotonin
are especially found in the brain and neurotransmitters in the brain and a lot of times when people
have uh lower levels a lot of times they get depression and so we put them on drugs that actually
stimulate dopamine and serotonin to be produced and so those would be anti-depressants but one of
the things that happens is people that are taking drugs for that they're taking it and what it does
is it increases the reward system the pleasure euphoria and compulsion areas of the brain and again
what that allows them to do is feel better and cope better because they're now producing more
dopamine and so a lot of times people that are depressed abuse drugs because it makes them feel
better and so it's because the repression is causing them not to make as many of these things so they
take drugs to stimulate and self-medicate and make them feel better about it and obviously these
things affect the reward system of the brain it affects it by drug addiction and again it's
characterized by compulsive consumption and an ability to control uptake because it does affect
these pathways it makes people feel better and so the reason why they take these drugs is then it
rewards them it makes them feel better and then they become addicted to those things and then it
can function and really affect mood memory processing sleep and cognition and so one of the issues with
people that have drug addictions is their their sleep cycles get really screwed up and they don't
sleep very well and they have lots of issues there as well and so you can see that drug addiction can
have a serious effect on the brain and again the reason why it becomes so addictive is due to the
the reward and motivation part of it and so the pleasure in euphoria also that come along with it
and they don't feel pain and so that's also one of the problems with drug addiction in those situations
now addictive drugs such as alcohol, cocaine, nicotine, and heroin enhance activity of the dopamine
pathway, secreasing more dopamine in those cases cocaine and amphetamines block the removal of
dopamine so you're triggering a good reward response and it makes you feel better and it makes you feel
like really excited and you know like I said before people that take amphetamines want to jump
through walls and that stuff and it speeds up their system so you see a lot of times athletes
abuse things things like what are called speed and amphetamines those are things that make you
feel really jumpy and jittery those are found in the again a lot in the cold medicines to help
you feel better and more responsive because a lot of times colds and that stuff kind of make you
feel like tired and way down and so one of the reasons why they put those drugs in there is to
make you feel more alert and awake and that and so that's what you see in those changes
now what happens during drug addiction it leads to long lasting changes in the reward circuit
circuitry causing cravings for the drug because you feel better and because of that you're getting
more dopamine more reward more reward and then when that goes away you feel lousy so you say well
I need more reward so I'm going to do this drug again and again so you feel better and again you
need more of it to feel better and so when you get addicted not only do you take it more but
you're stimulating more so you're getting more dopamine and so your body gets overwhelmed with
dopamine and so and that and even because of that now you need more to feel better and so
and that's what happens when people go off these drugs as a lot of times they have a lot of problems
because the nervous system needs those drugs to function or feels that it needs those drugs to
function and so they have a period of a number of days where they go off these drugs when they do
they have serious side effects where they get headaches and issues so they can have nervous system
issues like shakes and involuntary muscle control, vomiting, nausea, all these different things and
essentially that's where they're going off the drug and so that's the problem too and we even see
that with people that abuse caffeine and that maybe maybe you yourself if you drink a lot of soda or
like I said drink a lot of coffee and then you go off those things all of a sudden you get a headache
and that stuff and that's kind of your body saying hey get a little more caffeine you'll feel better
and so that's your body telling you that you need to take it when really you probably don't and
that's and that's again one of the things your body is telling you take it because it's helping
you it makes you feel better but it really isn't in the in the long sense of the word because you're
overwhelming your system and rewarding your system when it shouldn't be rewarded in that in that
matter so that's why drugs are bad and like I said we'll take a look at the drug mouse and we'll show
you exactly how that rewards the system and makes you feel good and and that and that's why it becomes
so addictive and a lot of these things these things allow you to do things where you're like oh it
makes me feel good so I'm going to take it again and again and again okay so let's talk a little bit
about some of the centers of the brain so first we're going to look at is the cerebrum and essentially
this is involving the cognitive functions that reside mainly in the cortex and the outer layer
and there's four lobes of the cerebrum there's the frontal lobe the parietal lobe the visual cortex
sometimes called the occipital lobe and then the temporal lobe which is for hearing as well as your
temperature and that stuff the hypothalamus and that which is tucked underneath there and that and
so that's kind of the called the temporal lobe and so you can see what these guys are involved with
really your frontal lobe is involved in decision-making planning and thinking the broca area which is
kind of in the middle of the frontal lobe which is the forming of speech the mortar cortex which
is kind of in the middle the somato sensory cortex which is touch again there's also for hearing
and then in the back you have the visual cortex which is in the back of the head and again the
occipital lobe and then the temporal you have the hearing back here the comprehending language is
kind of in the middle here and then the visual cortex which is down here so again kind of giving
you an idea so the front brain is kind of your thinking and in reasoning the the parietal lobe
is for senses the occipitals for sight and then the temporal lobe is going to be for hearing and
so that's kind of how you can think about these four parts of the frontal lobe now mapping of the
cognitive functions in the cortex being in the 1800s the broca area like it said is kind of in the
middle of the front brain so you can kind of see that right here you can see that generating words
is where speech is generated this is the broca broca a broca area of the brain so again the frontal
lobe right here kind of kind of towards the middle of the frontal lobe and then the hearing words is
in the temporal region which is closer to the back seeing words which is the visual cortex back here
and then speaking is kind of in the between the frontal kind of the back of the frontal lobe and
the some of the the parietal lobe in that where you have those two areas and again you can kind of
see where we here see speak and generate words and where the different areas of the brain light up
so it's kind of cool to see how that all works now we do have a left and right hemisphere of our
cerebrum and so you can see that the left side controls the logic analysis sequencing linear
mathematics language facts thinking of words and so people are either a lot of times they say
well my left brain is well developed and so i'm very analytical so again left brain over here
very analytical i you know i can understand things putting things in sequences orders i
understand a lot of things i know a lot of facts where some people are very right brain where they're
very creative so they are artists you know they have holistic thinking intuition
arts rhythm they can keep beats you know type of thing feelings visualization tunes uh songs
in daydreaming and and that's not to say that you know someone that's left brain is only left brain
they do have some characteristics to the right brain it's just the left brain is probably more
dominant in those uh characteristics just like those that are very creative are going to be more
right brain oriented doesn't mean that they don't have any of these things and some of these things
may be very strong but typically the right brain is going to be more dominant and that's where you're
going to see uh more of those things and again depending on the type of brain you have you're
going to kind of kind of know based on the type of uh region now most scientists are going to be
left brain because they like the analysis the sequencing the facts and those things so you're
going to see that that doesn't mean that you can't be creative and all those other things some people
are very uh both hemispheres where they have a mixture of both and they're very strong in both
and so that's probably the best of both worlds where you can really use both sides of brains and
work really well in those situations now here is that really cool picture as mentioning earlier
between the gray and the white matter so gray is on the outside and that's where most of the
neural bodies are you can see in this one the the neurons and the axons all coming together to
form the neurons this is the localization of the cortical function and again this is called the
corpus callosum that connects the two hemispheres together you can see everywhere else it's separated
and so again the right side and the left side are only connected here now people that have seizures
and Parkinson's a lot of times they'll actually get a surgery done which will actually sever
this corpus callosum so that the two hemispheres actually are separated out and what they find is
that it actually helps resolve a lot of seizures because a lot of times the seizures seizures are
referred to as electrical storms of the brain of the body where you're getting all these impulses
at once and you don't know what to do with them and so the body just doesn't know what to do and
it just kind of goes into these static convulsions and that and that's what happens with the seizure
now people with uh Parkinson's a lot of times they get tremors or shakes due to this nervous system
again sending out these signals and not receiving them very well and so they get these overall
shakes where they can't inhibit these responses and so what they find is if they sever the two
sides of the brain that it actually lowers the activity in both situations not only with seizures
but also with things in Parkinson's one of the probably the most famous cases of having this done
is Michael J. Fox who has severe Parkinson's and he actually had this surgery done and again it worked
for a while but he still has a lot he has a very severe case of Parkinson's where he just is constantly
shaking in that from his nervous system over responding and so one of the ways to kind of calm
that system down is by getting rid of this corpus callosum or slicing the corpus callosum just to
show you guys there now information processing like I said with the different lobes you have
different processing that goes on the somatosensory receptors which is found in the parietal lobe
is typically found in the back and then it also controls the motor functions that are going to go
out to the muscles and that the occipital lobe which is responsible for vision and then the temporal
lobe which is going to be for memory understanding the language we'll talk about that the motor cortex
which is part of between the frontal and the parietal lobe in the sensory is going to again
because you send stuff it's going to send the information the motor cortex is going to say okay
respond to that and then finally the frontal cortex is where you think and problem solve and do all
those things in the hypothalamus which is kind of located down underneath the temporal lobe here
it's kind of down in here directs the different types of input to the distinct location so it's
kind of one of those like the like I mentioned before the shipping center says where is this
information going to go and it's going to send it to the right spot and so that's where those
things happen now we have seen people that have had frontal lobe damage either from a car accident
or maybe a head wound or infection in this case you can see this guy had brain damage due to a
pipe going through his head and you can see that it went through the frontal lobe but it didn't
damage the back part of the brain and so in those situations you may have impaired decision-making
and emotional responses because again you lose some of that control where that is and so you lose
concentration you may lose speech smell may be affected because of that but you still have a lot
of the motor control touch and pressure the somatic and you may have memory and other things
because this part of the brain may not have been affected at all and vision as well and so you can
see even though you have damage in the front you may only have issues with that now one of the other
places that you that you hear about this now and again you've seen this in developmental biology
is that they say in young adults and in children this part of the brain is not as well developed
as some of the other parts of the brain in that this is actually one of the last parts to develop
and so one of the reasons why teenagers and young adults have bad behaviors sometimes
is because they're not capable of thinking about that and also you see a lot of ADHD and
that stuff because this part of the brain isn't as well developed at the time and you can see
that's for concentration planning and problem solving and so some people have an issue where
they're even getting too much stimulation or they can't block out the rest of the world and so they
have that problem and that's called ADHD where they're just very over active in that area also
people that have damage in that stuff have issues with the concentration problem solving in that as
well but one of the things that they say going back to my story is that in young adults this isn't
as well developed so you see a lot of times bad behavior or you see a lot of times where they don't
think about some of their actions so it's because they don't think about the consequences that can
happen and so that's it's hard for parents to understand why would you do that you know don't
you understand that and really one of the reasons why teenagers don't think about some of the
consequences is because that part of the brain isn't fully developed yet and so that's one of the
things so I guess that's a lesson for the parents out there that take this class is that don't be
so hard on your teenagers because maybe they're part of the brain hasn't fully developed yet
and you know I guess you guys that are teenagers taking the class you could use that as an excuse
well I didn't think about it because my brain isn't fully developed yet and that could be a true
statement in those situations and so they have found evidence for for that in the developmental
biology so that's just something to kind of mention at this point in time now what's interesting is
they thought that the infolding of the cerebellum in humans really allowed for the processing and
memory and all this other stuff and so there was a hypothesis out there saying higher order
reasoning requires highly convoluted cerebral cortex however they found that this might not
be true due to the cerebellum found in songbirds and that the cerebellum in songbirds actually has
no infolding but they have very important processing from the songs they understand what the songs are
what the messages are and how all that works and so that's one of the things that they look at and
how those things are actually generated and so that's one of one of the things that kind of refutes
that idea that that all this folding actually means that we can process better because songbirds
even though they don't have the folding can still respond pretty well and so that's the idea there
now appears they have what is called a play-em which is something that again allows them to process
without the infolines that go on there so the infolines may have occurred so you have higher
level consciousness and other things and able to respond but we know that the the cerebellum even
when they don't have the infolines still can process very well and then we see that with the songbirds
in that as well so just kind of looking at that now the last thing i'm going to talk about is neural
plasticity which is essentially the neurons being able to transmit and receive signals
and learn over time and create new connections between the brain and so we see that very well
now changes can strengthen or weaken the signal at the synapse and we do see in cases of autism
a developmental disorder that disruption of activity dependent remodeling doesn't occur
and so that tells us that these children can't learn as well because they don't have the same
plasticity or remodeling that goes on in a normal child and so that may be one of the reasons why
they have emotional as well as cognitive issues as as well as social interaction and that that
maybe these neurons are not able to figure out how to remodel and do the normal things that
our normal brain does and so when you learn things and when you learn things you're actually developing
new pathways and so that's why when they say when you learn stuff you should do a lot of different
things do visual do talking explain it because that allows for your brain to kind of remodel
the neurons in the brain and actually learn things better and so you see things more as
repetitive and and different types of things that allow for your brain to develop more neural
pathways and so the more more things that you do when you learn something and this is why i always
tell my students teach it to someone if you want to learn something really well the best way to
learn it is by teaching someone because it involves a lot of other senses it allows you to make
motor neurons work it makes you do all these different things you have to speak you have to
develop language you have to explain it and if you can explain it really well you're going to
learn it really well and so that's the idea and so if you ever do that little thing for AMP so they
a lot of times will have the seminar and it's it's for study skills because a lot of people don't know
really how to study they never learn how to study very well well one of the things they tell you is
about this neuroplasticity Dr. J does a really good job of talking about neuroplasticity and saying
that you create pathways by learning things and one of the ways to do that is by doing different
things and explaining it and teaching it is one of those ways and so they go through and they do
a really good job of explaining how it works and how you create these new pathways and different
methods to create these new pathways so that you actually learn these new behaviors and so that's
one of the cool things now the last thing we'll mention is again essential for forming memories
and you have short-term memories and long-term memories and so the short-term memory is thought
to be learned and kept in the hippocampus and I kind of think of this like a computer so in a
computer you really have two parts of memory you have what is called the RAM and then you have the
the basically the hard drive so you have the RAM and the hard drive the RAM is the the short-term
memory so what that does is it does the functions that you're doing right now and the more RAM you
have in your computer the faster it's going to work you can do multiple things at once
and you can get a lot of these short-term memories but in order to save something on your computer
like like this this PowerPoint you save it on your computer it goes into long-term memory so you
can bring it up and again and again and again and so that you have it saved in a nice local spot and
that's kind of what your brain does your brain will do short-term memory where it will process
these things and again in the hippocampus and that stuff in the lower end of the brain which will
allow you then to process things do things at you know normal human speed so that we can do these
things we can perceive we can receive send out signals do those things and look at those different
things but then when we want things to go in the long-term memory we transfer those things to the
cerebral cortex so we go into the green part of the brain so we go from the middle of the brain which
is where the hippocampus is and then we transfer that into the long-term memory and so we have the
working memory which is this part of the brain and then it gets transferred in the long-term like
the hard drive and so if you want to remember it over and over again we put that into long-term
memory and eventually that would come back to you and so again repetition doing those things
learning that processing it doing different things really help and again when you stimulate
more parts of the brain you really help long-term memory and so that's one of the reasons why you
learn something and so when you want to learn something really well explain it because then it
gets a lot of these other parts of the brain working and when that does you create long-term
memory and so that's one of the things that they say it doesn't go in and out of your ears
because a lot of times you do short-term memory where you just remember something for a short while
and it goes out if you really want to learn something really well explain it because then you
activate the rest of this part of your brain and then you'll learn it for a long time so that's the
key if you want to learn something for a long time explain it to someone get those other parts of
your brain working and then it's going to go into long-term memory the other thing they say and this
is a big problem too is that people don't get enough sleep and so if you don't get enough sleep
things don't go into long-term memory and that's the problem because you guys cram for tests and so
you get sleep deprived because you think about it the night before and you're like okay i gotta
remember this guy remember it it just stays in short-term memory so as soon as you're done with
the tests and you're done with it it goes right out your brain because you don't remember it because
you didn't use any of the other parts and then you didn't have the sleep to help push that into
long-term memory so you never had that go between the short-term and long-term and so you don't
remember it they're cramming doesn't it never allows you to learn long-term it only gets you the facts
for a short while because you don't have enough time to process it and send it out into long-term
memory and that's and that's where we see that and so again sleep and having good sleep is really
important to help establish that long-term memory as well so that's the key good sleep
and explain it if you can explain it in good sleep you're going to remember stuff quite well
throughout your life and that's and that's the key okay so we made it to the end of this
presentation so again we talked about the nervous system consisting of circuits and
neurons and supporting cells we talked about the central nervous system and the peripheral
central is the brain and spinal cords that really integrate and interpret the message that come in
the peripheral nervous system are sensing and then responding and so that's what you see those
are the ones that lead out of the central central nervous system and again we can break down the
peripheral nervous system into three parts you have the this while really four because you have the
the sensing part okay which is receiving the signals from the outside world then you have the motor
neurons which are sending out the signals back out so controlling the muscles and response and
then you have the autonomic nervous system which can be broken down into really three more parts in
that state so I guess there's three the sensing the motor and the autonomic and then the autonomic
can be broken down to the the synaptic and then the asynaptic and so the synaptic is again the
fight or flight so that you have again the if you got to respond right away take away the stuff
from the digestive and go go go fight or flight and then you have the asymptomatic which is
essentially where you shut down the the fight or flight and now it's the rest and digestive thing
calmed down and then you have the enteric which really is responsible for controlling the enteric
system so we talked about that the other big thing out of there that we got was the glia cells and
how they protect nourish and talk about that and we learned about that in chapter 37 then the rest
of time we spent looking at the brain the vertebrate brain is regionally specialized we didn't really
talk too much about the pons in the medulla vlogata those are responsible for the involuntary the
smooth muscle control of the the organs the beating of the heart the breathing of the diaphragm all
that good stuff that's in there uh the cerebellum in the we didn't really talk much about the cerebellum
or but we spent most of our time on the cerebrum i should probably add stuff on that just so you
have those things for you guys but we'll we'll get in more of that uh the cerebellum again is divided
into the different uh lobes you have the frontal lobe the parietal lobe the occipital lobe and the
temporal lobe in each one does a little bit different the frontal lobe is more for thinking and reasoning
and cognitive ability uh the the parietal lobe is more about the sensing uh in the sensing of the
world touch and that and then responding to that uh the occipital lobe is more the visual cortex and
then finally the uh temporal lobe is going to be again a lot of the regulation and then hearing
and then some of the other things that are out there so uh senses all that other good stuff emotions
that's what you're going to see there in that in in that in that part of the brain okay and then
finally the cerebral cortex controls the voluntary movement and cognitive functions we talked about
that the frontal versus the parietal and nearly in between is the motor motor uh cortex which is
controlling all the muscle movement in that and so that's what we looked at today so if you have
any questions about the brain i know a little bit you know i'm getting better at it i'm learning a
little bit more and that stuff as i go on and i cuz as i'm explaining it to you guys but if you
do have questions about parts of the brain and that stuff i'll bring out the models and that stuff
in lab and we can look at the different parts of the brain and then look at functions and talk
about that uh the next next couple of weeks in lab otherwise if you have any questions send me an
email again uh and we'll go over and talk about in class i thank you for watching and i'll see you next